bonjour à merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors vladimir
poutine a évoqué la vaccination est
aussi le marché énergétique des sujets
très importants pour la russie
sont des sujets qui sont actuellement à
l'agenda de qui les paie puisque ce sont
des sujets de l'agenda global hisse donc
effectivement il est très intéressant
que la dîme et poutine et clarifier la
situation puisque beaucoup de mouvements
sociaux et beaucoup de politiques
s'intéressaient de savoir quelle est
finalement la position de la russie du
président russe sur la question de la
vaccination il a bien indiqué que pour
la russie l'important est donc dans vos
connaissances vaccin que le vaccin est
une des conditions de reprise de
l'activité économique globale ce qui
veut dire qu'il soutient donc la
vaccination est ce que l'on voit à
l'intérieur du pays des factures
aujourd'hui alors pour la vaccination à
vladimir poutine a évoqué je le cite en
une concurrence déloyale comme un kinder
le fait que la russie soit entrée dans
le jeu de la production et de la
diffusion du vaccin veut dire qu'elle
est entrée dans le jeu de la concurrence
de la vente en commercial du vaccin or
il est évident que l'accès de la russie
au marché que ce soit pour le vaccin qui
soit pour toute autre production plus
est conditionnée également par des
rapports politiques et comme nous le
voyons les agence européenne de
médicaments l'om est un trend à chaque
fois et roue à chaque fois des excuses
des prétextes pour ne pas reconnaître le
vaccin bus qui est manifestement
idéologiquement incompatibles alors que
finalement au niveau des résultats des
effets sont quasiment les mêmes que les
vaccins américain 1 qui sont qui sont
produits donc ciblé de ce côté là
iliad set 7 jeux ce jeu de la russie
dans la production de vaccins elle
estime qu' il est de son intérêt
national d'avoir sa propre vaccination
et il est souhaitable quand même qu'un
de réduire à sa souveraineté à la
capacité de lire votre saoul alors son
absence en ai remarqué en tout cas
absence
physique est ce que selon vous il ya une
portée symbolique à cette absence
la russie est absente au niveau de la
représentation des chefs d'état en
revanche la broche de la sergueï lavrov
mi6 affaires étrangères lui est présent
donc on peut pas dire que la russie soit
complètement absents en ce qui concerne
l'absence du président oui de toute
manière comme nous avons pu le roi ne
vous ont pu le lire dans différents
médias et à juste titre on attend assez
peu de choses en fait de cette réunion
du g20 qui a globalement sur des
questions qui sont avancés n'a rien
filmé en de très nouveau puisque le
climat ça fait des années que les
questions sont avancés les questions la
tradition libéré explique des années que
cette avancée il ya certes une
utilisation de la situation en tout cas
du vaccin dur du coc vide pour
développer ces questions et les
renforcer mais globalement rien ne
change au niveau du discours depuis des
années donc la présence de la russie
sur ces questions n'apporte pas grand
chose surtout que sa position est connue
justement sur cette question et surtout
dans un contexte géopolitique
particulièrement crispé lorsque l'on
voit des provocations assez importante
que ce soit du côté de l'otan a que ce
soit du côté des états unis directement
avec une certaines plantations de
méthanisation de la mer noire par
exemple de réactivation du conflit en
ukraine il est évident que globalement
si la russie doit formellement
participer à une réunion du g20 il n'y a
strictement aucune exigence est ce que
le président soit personnellement
présent dans le cadre géopolitique aussi
tendu entre de russie d'ailleurs
vladimir poutine en l'a rappelé en tout
cas rater l'objectif de ce sommet à des
discussions de travail hors de toute
discrimination le message est clair
tout à fait la russie est un acteur
important sur la scène internationale et
elle estime que toute discussion qui
doit être menée doit permettre à
l'avancé du dialogue ce n'est pas
discuté pour discuter pour qu'un
dialogue puisse avancer il faut que les
partenaires puissent discuter sur un
plan d'égalité or nous avons vu ces
derniers mois que
que ce soit au niveau des déclarations
particulièrement agressive de
l'allemagne que ce soit au niveau des
par exemple de l'otan qui ferment dh qui
réduit la représentation de la russie à
ce sont des démarches qui visent à
priori à contenir la russie ce ne sont
pas des démarches qui visent à instaurer
un climat de confiance et un dialogue
karine berger goal com merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou mercière
merci